dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if ahead our
endeavors in creating amazingly detailed
fluid simulations is often hamstrung by
the fact that we need to simulate the
motion of tens of millions of particles
needless to say this means excruciating
ly long computation times and large
memory consumption this piece of work
tries to alleviate the problem by
confining the usage of particles to a
narrowband close to the liquid surface
and thus decimating the number of
particles used in the simulation the
rest of the simulation is computed on a
very coarse grid where we compute
quantities of the fluid like velocity
and pressure in grid points and instead
of computing them everywhere we try to
guess what is happening between these
grid points the drawback of this is that
we may miss a lot of details because of
that and the brilliant part of this new
technique is that we only use a cheap
sparse grid where there is not a lot of
things happening and use the expensive
particles only near the surface where
there are a lot of details we can
capture well the flipped term that you
see in the video means fluid implicit
particle a popular way of simulating
fluids that uses both grids and
particles in this scene the old method
uses 24 million particles while the new
technique uses only 1 million and
creates closely matching results you can
see a lot of excess particles in the
footage with the classical simulation
technique and the foam each looking
version is the proposed new more
efficient algorithm creating such a
technique is anything but trivial unless
special measures are taken the
simulation may have robustness issues
which means that there are situations
where it does not produce a sensible
result this is demonstrated in a few
examples where we the naive version of
the technique a piece of fluid never
ever comes to rest or it may exhibit
behaviors that are clearly unstable
it also takes approximately half as much
time to run the simulation and uses half
as much memory which is a huge relief
for visual effects artists I don't know
about you fellow scholars but I see a
flood of
amazing fluid papers coming in the near
future and I'm having quite a bit of
trouble containing my excitement
exciting times are ahead indeed thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time